they knew it was coming India's coastal
state of Odisha was braced for the worst
more than a million people were
evacuated ahead of the storm
but the coastal resort of Puri still
suffered extensive damage the storm
brought down trees and powerlines as it
moved inland in booba Nicoise our dishes
state capital the streets were deserted
the storm left chaos behind it and
although it is expected to weaken over
the coming hours authorities are still
warning people to be careful along the
coastline go inside the Civic Arena
why because it is now a high sensitive
so you are in the assistance of the
police an obsession and the NDRF team we
are providing the all the local people
and the viewers not to go inside the CBI
reader and that is dangerous
for now it seems that the evacuation
plans have paid off but once the storm
has died down people in Odisha will have
to be ready for a lengthy cleanup
operation mishima joyce val is covering
the story for us from Delhi
Mishima we just heard in the piece that
evacuations have largely paid off but
clearly evacuations alone couldn't
prevent other problems could you tell us
more about that have had a positive
impact when it comes to the cost of
human lives but infrastructure has been
damaged heavily all across the state of
Orissa
and now the cyclone is moving into the
state of West Bengal the coastal areas
have been heavily inundated but in fact
some of the loss of life that has been
reported has occurred because of falling
communication poles calling telephonic
poles trains toppling over buildings
being impacted the construction of the
house is not being sturdy enough now I
have to draw a comparison to the last
super cyclone that hit Russia in 1999
two decades ago two decades India has
actually perfected its response system
when it comes to human cost because
10,000 lives were lost back in 99 but
when it comes to infrastructure costs
India has moved
relatively slowly it has committed more
recently to improving resilient disaster
resilient infrastructure because with
global warming extreme weather events or
ews are becoming more frequent but given
how slow and are just the processes of
building up infrastructure is the road
ahead is going to be a tough one for
India how is the situation now well as I
mentioned there is heavy damage all
along the coast in many of the cities in
Odisha as well rural areas of course
because the houses are patched many
people have been displaced a million
people were evacuated in advance which
is where the human cost has been reduced
but these people now have to be have to
have to be supported by central
authorities the Indian Navy and the
Indian Coast Guard was deployed the
national disaster relief force of India
is one of the largest in the world and
they are bringing medicines and food to
the people they have deployed generators
so that the people can have electricity
but when it comes to when these people
can actually go back to their homes if
their homes are still standing the road
ahead is going to be an arduous one
because it's going to require a lot of
restoration work to make it possible for
them to go back what can you tell us
about how this cyclone will develop
within the next 24 hours or so well
today already the cyclone has reached
the state of West Bengal in India as I
mentioned and as it has proceeded it has
been continuously weakening in the first
six hours after it made landfall
yesterday it was extremely severe but as
the time passes it is being downgraded
to very severe and severe categories
there is heavy rain in West Bengal and
this wind but it is no not at all as
damaging as it was yesterday however
authorities have said that people must
be careful and must not get complacent
because such wind speeds are still
dangerous they could still be crossing a
hundred kilometers per hour and of
course it is now expected to leave India
and pass into Bangladesh which also has
to be ready to make sure that its own
people are not impacted heavily by
cyclone funny
Hashima thanks so much for joining us
appreciate that update